[Applause]
[Applause]
hello everyone I Trevor I want to
welcome you to Miami and welcome you to
the Miami Book Fair thank you so much
thank you for having me and thank you
for coming out of the day and I really
want to congratulate you on writing a
phenomenal book I've I've sort of been
engrossed in it for the last couple of
weeks and I found that poignant scary
funny and I learned a lot about South
Africa that I I never would have
otherwise known I really thank you for
that thank you thank you for being so
truthful thank you I appreciate it thank
you that I recognized I recognized that
many of you in this room have and your
family members have shed a lot of tears
since last Tuesday and are keenly
interested in hearing Trevor's take on
what happened and I assure you that
whether we get to it in our conversation
or not there is an opportunity after
there's going to be a question and
answer period and you can ask Trevor all
about that so um so Trevor let me start
with the title of your book it's born a
crime what what did you mean by that
well I was born at a time when in South
Africa due to the laws of apartheid my
parents weren't allowed to be in any
shape or form in contact with one
another you know I grew up during a time
when we were governed by the laws of
message' nation as they were called
interracial relationships were forbidden
the mixing of races was forbidden and so
essentially I mean being born from my
parents
white Swiss man and
a black Casa woman from South Africa I
was essentially born a crime you know
the very the very existence of me was
something that was against the law what
my parents had done was breaking the law
and because of that our lives were
impact in the way we could live as a
family under those laws of apartheid
now you're born in 1984 how did you
interact with your mother your black
mother and your your white father well
lucky for me I interacted with them like
a child yeah you know I I was very lucky
in that my parents did a great job of
shielding me from the realities of what
was going on in the country I only knew
the world that I was in and I was only
surrounded by people who were in the
same world as I so you know ignorant
truly was bliss in that regard I knew I
had a father who was white but I didn't
know that he was a white person I just
knew that he was my father I knew that I
had a mom who was black but again her
race meant nothing to me because at the
time that was the only way I knew it to
be you know I thought fathers were
whites and then uncles were black and
that's how the world works
so so I was I was I was truly shielded
from the from the stress of what was
happening in the country at the time it
was only as we started transitioning and
as I got older I started realizing and I
was really lucky that I was on the cusp
of a country achieving democracy and
equality before I became a fully
functioning human being so when you were
young could you go to the park with your
mother and father and play like other
kids were playing and well I I could the
question I guess is where we allow to
and that was the that was the key thing
we couldn't be seen in public together
you know my mother broke many laws by
living where she lived she and I writes
about this in the book she illegally
rented an apartment in an area that was
considered a white area and so what she
does she would masquerade as our maid
you know as my maid and that's how she'd
walk around with me she'd dress in in
maids overalls and that's how we'd get
around you know she found ways to
circumvent the system she found ways to
get around rules that she didn't agree
with and and so for me I'm I still
played with my mother
you know because from the outside I
don't I don't know what it looked like
to everyone but a lot of people just
assumed that that black woman was the
caretaker of this child who was in South
Africa considered colored and my father
on they had that and he couldn't he
couldn't be with us at all in public
there were times when we were together
but he wouldn't play the role of a
father because then that would give the
game away so so that was a limitation
but I mean I the one story I tell in the
book is when I was really young I used
to love running I mean I still do but I
would go out with my mom and dad and if
we were in public in a park together the
only limitation was that I couldn't get
too close to him I couldn't you know be
seen as his son and so I I would chase
him as any child would their father but
then he would run away
to protect us and then I was like yeah
the game is on so I would chase him and
my mother would be chasing me and so I
like many other children have great
memories of running in the park with my
parents the only differences they see it
from a slightly different perspective
and you you talk about the book that
when you visit your grandmother in
Soweto how frightened they were of you
being out in the street yeah yeah well
that you know what that was that was one
of the the moments when I learned in the
book I only realized that when I was
writing the book I I tried to write
everything from memory but for for some
stories I felt like I had pieces missing
and so I went back and I asked my
grandmother and my mom about a few of
the stories and one that fascinated me
as well as I grown up my entire life as
a child who was basically locked indoors
I was an indoor kid and I didn't suffer
I loved reading I loved staying indoors
and I was in my own world
and I always knew my grandmother would
wouldn't allow me to go outside because
she was afraid that they would steal me
that's all she'd say they'll steal you
they'll steal you and whenever she said
that I assumed she meant the neighbors
or you know kidnappers in the the
neighborhood or I just I assumed it was
just people only when I went back to
talk to her about the book I came to
learn from her that she was afraid that
the police would take me away because if
they saw me in a black area they would
know immediately that I didn't belong
just because of the laws and they would
have every right to take me send me off
to an orphanage and my family would
never see me again so again like I
learned and this was as a grown man I
didn't even know how died the the
situation actually was so you didn't in
tone like working on the book realized
why everyone always wanted Trevor to
stay inside oh yeah yeah I was I mean
don't get me wrong I was also a
terrorist so I was just like you just
protecting the world that's what I
thought some of it was
the the book you make I think repeated
references to recognizing and you say at
different ways the genius of apartheid
how the architects of apartheid built
the most advanced system of racial
oppression known to man what about it
makes you describe it in that way well
because you you have to acknowledge it's
it's an insane amount of hard work that
went into building such an abominable
system you know apartheid was perfect
racism it was a system designed to
oppress a majority because America and
South Africa share a lot of similarities
in terms of a racial history in terms of
reckoning with that racial history in
the present but one place where it was
different is that in in South Africa
black people are the majority and so the
question is how do you oppress the
majority it's extremely difficult how do
you how do you make the majority unable
to stand up and the apartheid government
was really really committed to finding a
way to do that and they studied racism
from all over the world you know from
the Dutch from Australia from the United
States they looked at all different
systems and coalesced them into finding
the perfect racism and so they found
that the key was to separate people into
the most I guess it was the minutia of
the groups you know finding ways to
convince people that they were different
even when they were not and so they
didn't see black as a monolith as it's
seen in America they said no we're gonna
divide you up into your tribes we'll
divide you into shades of your darkness
and that's where colored came from you
know in America if you're a bi-racial
person who is half black half white most
of the time you categorized as black and
in South Africa they didn't do that and
the skill there was dividing people up
by their language by their culture by
their by their tribe and creating
smaller groups that you could put
against each other
and have dominion over within within the
regime so it was it was really scary and
it was really well thought out I was
going I wanted like sometimes why
racists like they really committed I
wonder why they don't just commit to
making the world a better place cuz I
mean they're very good at what they do
sometimes wish we talked a lot about how
important language is and was to keeping
people separate how did it play out in
into the the apartheid sort of design
well there were different ways you know
it was everything from the schooling
system in which children were taught in
languages that weren't there's certain
languages were prioritized above others
language was one of the biggest barriers
you know in terms of giving a person an
opportunity to switch from one world to
another and one thing I grew up
realizing was the power of language you
know I have the quote in the book and it
was Nelson Mandela who said if you if
you speak to a man in a language he
understands you speak to his head you
speak to a man in his language and you
speak to his heart and the power of
language is something that I've learned
over the years in that it's one of the
biggest things that divides people and
you essentially there's nothing there
it's just a minute miscommunication is
just people perceiving a difference you
know just based on how you communicate
using a different language and what I
learned very quickly my family did and
even in the country we realized that
language was a tool that you could use
to divide people and also bring them
together and I learned in my life every
time I learned a new language I gained
entry into another world
I gained insights into another way of
living into another way of thinking and
probably one of the biggest gifts I
think I gained from learning languages
and I continued get to gain I try and
learn as many as I can is I think it's
always a it's a constant humility that's
forced on you because when you
new language you you can't be arrogant
about it you have to be a child again
you have to accept that you're gonna be
stupid again you have to accept that you
can't be superior again you know because
you probably don't know what superior is
in that language but but it but it's
really something that that's why I you
know I advocate for that with everyone I
go just just learn a new language it's
not about being good or not just try and
learn a new language because you'll be
surprised at how it activates different
parts of your mind in thinking about
other people well if you learn new
languages did it surprise your fellow
countrymen that there's this colored
person would be speaking languages other
than Afrikaner or English or whatever it
may be
oh yeah definitely definitely I came
from a country where that you know in
terms of a ranking English and Afrikaans
which is a which is a I guess a subset
of Dutch those were the two languages
that were spoken and those are the two
languages that you needed everything
else was was considered the riffraff
everything else was considered below it
was sub there was nothing that was to be
aspire to and so you had all these
tribes in South Africa and you still do
people who speak their their language at
home and then they'll speak the language
of the colonizers whether it be the
English or that Afrikaans
and I found one of the best ways in one
of the quickest ways I could connect
with people was to try and learn their
language
you know fellow South Africans where you
know I didn't understand how we were
separated until I came to realise that
language was a great tool that could be
used to separate people because
fundamentally if you cannot understand
the person as stupid as it sounds you
cannot understand the person and so I
set out to do that and I found that it
was it was one of the the most amazing
things I did even for myself even as a
for a selfish reason I found I could
connect to people and it gave me access
to worlds that I never would have had
access yeah it seemed like I'm gonna
give some of these compelling stories
away but that there are instances where
because of your ability to speak
language you're able to maneuver in
worlds that
I never have otherwise been able to to
maneuver and accept yeah definitely
that's that's exactly what it is and at
the same time currently there's South
Africa has 11 national languages that's
true and that's I guess I said the
leftover or what I think happened was we
came from a place where some languages
were put above others and so once we
achieve democracy the question was what
now becomes our official language and I
guess because we had come from a world
where no one wants to put anything below
or above another thing it was just like
let's just make them all official
languages and so we ended up with
official languages and I think it's four
or five languages in the in the national
anthem as well which is extremely
difficult but but I guess you know
everyone's hearts were in the right
place
yeah the and your grandmother lived in
Soweto yes nice and it still does and
you which spends a lot of time there is
that I did yeah and you for Americans
and like least speak for myself well I
think a lot of Americans associate
Soweto with sort of the source of
uprisings against apartheid yes home
over nasty where Nelson Mandela lived
you describe it at least it to me in an
interesting way you describe the stark
poverty of Soweto but you also write and
I'm quoting here he says something
magical about Soweto yes it's a prison
designed by our oppressors but it also
gave us a sense of self-determination
what what did you mean by that well I
think what I what I meant by that was
completely what I felt by being in the
place and that was the the strength of
of the human being the ability of the
human being to overcome situations that
may seem like they're designed to
oppress or have been
to to oppress you know Soweto is one of
those examples people moved from
different places where they lived black
people relocated forcefully taken out of
certain areas that were taken away from
black people and given to why people and
then they were forced to live in this
new place with with almost nothing and
and yet from that nothing came so many
amazing stories came so many amazing
ideas so many amazing leaders because
essentially the one thing that I think
the apartheid government didn't think
about was when they created so where to
what they essentially did was they
created a home base for thought they
created a space where people could exist
and galvanize within and what happened
was it was one of the birthplaces of the
struggle it was one of the birthplaces
of protests it was one of the
birthplaces of South Africa's identity
in terms of the politics that emerged
because black people were forced to
create and fend for themselves this
wasn't a space that was promoted by the
government and so the people found a way
to create micro economies you know
whether it be stores that became
resellers of food you know people who
set up their own auto shops to fix cause
you know people created different
economies even public transportation
that wasn't provided by the government
they found ways to formalize what was an
informal system and create that
themselves and I think that was
essentially what happened is in trying
to keep a group of people separated and
helpless and hopeless what in what ended
up happening I guess unintentionally is
through the resolve of the of the people
who in Soweto those people became
hopeful powerful and more determined
than ever because they became
self-reliance and they saw the fruits of
their labor
and what really emerged from that was a
fire that couldn't be extinguished by a
hateful government they described it as
having no running
[Applause]
there wasn't running water in people's
homes their multiple family households
would share one toilet yeah there
weren't shops - weren't I mean it was it
just seems so desolate other than the
the police force that might have where
this it wasn't police as we know but was
like the SWAT team that would yeah yeah
it was a heavily militarized force yeah
but you know you know that's that's one
of the the funny things the the the side
effect of that is you know I know some
people disagree many people do agree but
you know that where they talk about the
moral arc of the universe bending
towards justice essentially that was the
one thing that came out of saw it so we
lived in a world where I shared a toilet
with four different families we shared a
toilet we shared one tap at one point to
get our water from you know we shared a
piece of land and essentially what what
happened was that was what became the
strength of the community because we
weren't living in this world where we
didn't know our neighbors we weren't
living in a world where we weren't
talking to the people around us we
weren't living in a world where we were
isolated and having an experience by
ourselves what in effect happened was
because of the way it was set up the
government without realizing it's
enabled the people to find each other
within those spaces and so it was
terrible and it wasn't a great way to
live but as I say the unintended
consequences of that was it created
community the inner I think I told you
we were just talking before how much I
learned from your book and one thing I
learned was thinking that the the Sue
Etta was a was an African name only to
learn after reading your book that it's
really an acronym for Southwest Township
yeah yeah but that's but that's exactly
that's that's what I'm talking about the
power to reclaim something and and take
it away from someone who thought they
were they were oppressing you because it
is now an African word it is something
that we proudly claimed so where's my
home and we say it as the African place
that it is in 1990 apartheid
it's ended and Nelson Mandela was
released or there were no elections I
think it's in 1994 Yeah right and I
think a great expression in your
description and your book is that the
end of apartheid wasn't like the Berlin
Wall coming crashing down but it was
like a slow crumbling yes what was your
life like not your six years old as a
colored person in South Africa as
apartheid started to end and get this
mantle well as I tell in the book I
never discount the fact that I'm
extremely lucky in that were where I
born a few years earlier I would have
been subjected to so much more of the
racism in my country were I born years
later I may not have appreciated the
hardship from whence freedom came being
born at the time that I was I was old
enough to see the transition I was old
enough to see democracy take hold and
yet at the same time I was young enough
to recover from the effects of people
not being afforded that democracy and
when apartheid ended it was it was a
very gradual thing I mean America has a
similar history with the abolishment of
slavery
or even the civil rights movement it
doesn't happen overnight you know it's
not as a paper that you sign and then
people just go okay I guess we were
wrong let's go home you know there's a
lot of convincing that has to be done
there's still a gradual process and
that's that's probably one of the
greatest challenges and and I speak
about that in the book as well is that
I've come to realize that it's
frustrating especially for people who
have been oppressed when you come to
realize that freedom is just the
beginning
you know freedom is just the beginning
of the journey a lot of the time we
think of it as the end and yet it's not
I sometimes think of barriers where
there be racial with it
gender whether it be you know whatever
that whatever the barriers are I always
think of it as when you get when you
break that barrier down so when people
of color achieve equality when women
achieve equality with when that happens
all that's happened is you've been
allowed access to now climb the mountain
freedom is just getting there now you
still have to climb this mountain that's
that's before you and that's what we
came to realize in South Africa was it
was this wonderful moment and it was
really a honeymoon period because it was
amazing freedom that and there and the
and the feeling was a special thing and
then we were like oh wow this is now a
lot of hard work well you talk about now
the black man can Robo which black men
say can that you said in the book you
talk about how now black black men can
rule but which black men are going to
rule oh yeah yeah I mean that became a
you know an issue because sometimes you
don't think it'll ever end especially
when you're oppressed you go it's never
gonna end and then when it ends you you
find a place where everything was geared
towards seeking out freedom and you know
it's almost as if those not all of those
leaders who would we're geared towards
fighting for freedom are the same
leaders who can now move forward once
freedom has been achieved and that's a
very tough thing that we see in many
countries all over the world a lot of
the time the liberators end up becoming
the oppressors you know they they take
over they free the people
and once that freedom is achieved
there's no longer anything to fight over
and then so many times we see this I
know it happens in South Africa I know
it happens in many countries where the
liberators start stuffing their own
pockets now and they start enriching
themselves and the next thing you know
you're in a in the same cycle and it's
just the face at the top has changed and
the label has shifted but it doesn't
feel like anything has moved for the
people where did you as a colored person
fit in as apartheid was being dismantled
well I was I was lucky I was extremely
lucky in that my mother always lived as
an outsider so to give you to give you
an understanding of this for for people
who may not know in South Africa all of
the races were broken down so white
being
superior and then the darker your skin
tone became the fewer liberties you were
afforded you know and this list affected
everything from the jobs you could have
to the education you could receive to
even how you were treated in prison the
meals you would get and what you could
wear within a prison and so as strange
as it sounds because of my skin color I
was considered a superior race to my own
mother I was considered an inferior race
to my own father you know so I was in a
will so that that's what colored means
in South Africa it doesn't mean anything
with regards to black the same way you
know the way it does in America and so I
grew up in this world where I grew up in
a black family I grew up living the
black experience what happened was the
country wanted to define me as something
else because of how I looked my mother
on the other hand was a rebel I mean she
you know had a child from a white man
that tells you everything you know
during the time so so essentially I
existed in a space where I knew that I
wasn't defined by the labels that were
was set out for me because we never fit
in my family didn't match any family
around me there were no other white or
colored people in my in my neighborhood
in Orlando East where I grew up I mean
still under West and so that that was
something that's that I don't think I
don't think it was allowed to affect me
because of the world I grew up in it was
something that my mom's like really
fought against because she didn't
believe in us being defined by what
people wanted to define us as with your
ability to speak different languages
that you find yourself you know fitting
in or identifying with different groups
at different times yeah yeah III I grew
up as an outsider and one of the
greatest gifts I feel you know it's it's
it's really hard to be an outsider most
of the time because you feel like
exactly that an outsider you feel like
you never belong the most amazing gift
that I feel you receive from being an
outsider
is that it forces perspective on you you
cannot exist in a bubble because you
were always in somebody else's bubble
you always have to see somebody else's
points of view because most of the time
you are in their world and so language
was one of those things I would have to
adopt somebody else's language and live
within it to live within a different
community to communicate with different
people but because of that it shaped me
in different ways it gave me access to
thoughts ideas and even experiences that
I never would have had after as
apartheid was was was you know coming
down did some coloreds tend to colored
persons tend to relate more to the white
person the white community as opposed to
the black community or remain colored
what was definitely I you know the in
terms of the way the apartheid was
structured in such a way that's and
again I mean this is you know I want to
spoil all of the things from the book
but like the idea was that you could
convince people and we still see this
every day people are convinced that the
reason they aren't achieving is because
of another group or another race that is
holding them back you know and now we're
living through the time where it is a
lot of the time you know a white voice
that is spreading that message and that
is and that's what the government did in
South Africa they reached out and they
said to color people you you're almost
white
you're almost there just a few shades
and you could do it but unfortunately
you've still got that a little bit of
black in you and so you know you never
know if you if you breed correctly for a
few generations if you if you marry
rights you may be able to ascend to a
place of being white and this sounds
ridiculous but every year in South
Africa people could be reclassified
racially so if you were a colored person
whose hair becomes straight enough and
your face became light enough you could
be reclassified as a white person
the same could happen inversely if you
were seen to be getting too dark too
much time in the Sun you could be
reclassified as now a colored person
from a white person and they didn't care
about your genealogy that it all went on
appearances because it is ridiculous at
the end of the day and so the laws had
to be ridiculous too to echo the
ridiculousness of the ideas so so what
happened was there were people who
resented any part of themselves that was
connected to what they were told was
inferior there were people who resented
the idea that they came from a place an
idea an identity or people who in some
of their minds were holding them back as
opposed to going we need to rise up and
not rise up to the level of the white
man but rather rise up to where we
belong in society you know achieve our
equality instead it was an attitude of
leave them behind and let's try aspire
to get to the place that the white man
said we can get you the I think
unmistakeably the the hero of your book
is your mom yes I mean I think it speaks
really loud and clear I'm gonna just
read you quickly a passage and ask you
to comment this that really struck me as
to how special she was um is because my
mom raised me as if there were no
limitations on where I could go or what
I could do when I look back I realize
she raised me like a white kid not white
culturally but in the sense of believing
that the world was my oyster that I
should speak up for myself that my ideas
and thoughts and decisions mattered my
mother showed me what was possible the
thing that always amazed me about her
life is that no one showed her no one
chose her she did it on her own she
found her way through sheer force of
will
I was nearly 6 when Mandela was released
10 before democracy finally came yet she
was prepared
me to live a life of freedom long before
we knew freedom would exist
[Music]
can you sort of comment on that there
well one thing we couldn't deny growing
up was we were living in a police state
and one of the biggest things we were
taught growing up where those my
grandmother my grandfather my aunt who
ever it was was as a black child you had
to be twice as good you knew that you
weren't afforded the same liberties you
weren't allowed to be making the same
mistakes because there was a system that
was waiting to imprison or kill you and
so you always had to be twice as good
twice as polite twice as you know just
twice as a human being and my mom to a
certain extent bucked that trend in that
system she brought me up as if I would
be in a world where I was free to
express myself she brought me up as if I
was going to live in a world where I
wouldn't be oppressed now that I guess
you know it's an extremely it's an
extremely risky gamble because she she
had no idea that it would end but we
lived as if did as if it would and so my
mom always told me she said speak up you
know you know voice your concerns
challenging me as your mother that was
the one thing my mom you know imbued
within me was the idea that I could
challenge her Authority don't get me
wrong I mean I was still on the end of
many many spankings from her but but I
was told that I could challenge her
because in challenging her we would both
learn and I still try and keep that with
me today I tell people like I'm proud to
say that I don't know I don't know most
things and what's great about not
knowing is is the joy of filling in that
void or even knowing that you can still
learn new things a lot of the time I
don't know why we learn our entire lives
and then we become adults and we go like
oh we know now we're done we know and we
don't there's always something new to
learn there's always an idea that we
can't change but my mom
always
always encourage sex before we go to
questions oh that's just one final kind
of question for you Trevor and I and and
again this is something that in sort of
looking at at sort of have different
things for our discussion today again
really struck me in it when you were
announced to be the new host of The
Daily Show The Guardian newspaper the
noted in reference to your selection of
quoting this is a big achievement not
only for South Africa but for the
continent and then I look up Google and
South Africa has 55 million people
there's 1.2 billion people in Africa do
you see yourself as a trailblazer for
others but from South Africa and from
Africa by taking on this such a
prominent important position in sort of
the US entertainment room I see myself
as more of a proud citizen you know I've
always considered myself a citizen of
the world and once I was afforded the
ability to travel I I've graciously
crossed that with both hands and I
embraced it I always tell people to
travel I go just try try and travel you
know my favorite quotes is that
traveling is the antidote to ignorance
and I truly believe that it is and so
[Applause]
for me I you know I'm really proud to
come from a country where we achieved
odds you know we we achieved over the
odds that were insurmountable we did
things that no one believed could be
done you know we had a bloodless
revolution in South Africa and it's not
a perfect country but we managed to find
a way to shift power from my doing a
minority that was essentially running a
dictatorship and and moving that over to
the majority that was running the
country and still is and it's not
overnight that's what I say freedom is a
lot of hard work but I feel like I came
from an exceptional place you know I
came from a country that's a that's a
trailblazer and so I'm honored to be a
child of South Africa and of Africa and
when I got into the world I celebrate
that I celebrate my heritage I still
have so much to learn about Africa as a
whole I mean it's again it's not a
country which is a surprise to some
people but but I do consider myself an
African as much as I do a South African
because of how many stories we share
across the continents how many trials
and tribulations we've we've been forged
you know in together
and so I see myself as less of a
trailblazer and more of somebody who is
rising to Heights because of those who
rose before me and that was one of the
the main things my mom said to me and in
the book I have it is the biggest thing
my mom wanted or she said every
generation should be further forward
than the one that came before it that's
all she wants
was just for one generation to move the
ball forward for the next you ever think
I use our questions we do have some time
for questions just a few if you can come
up there's a mic right ear so just line
up again you know as all of you know
treasure has Trevor has a day job a day
job yeah a nighttime day job he'll be
traveling we were on a really tight
schedule so we're only going to be able
to take a few questions to allow him to
make it back
and everyone's lining up I guess we'll
do the will do the daily show tomorrow
right from this spot let's take the
first question right Thank You Trevor I
enjoyed so much hearing you my name is
shankha thank you thank you I same I led
a tour group in 1994 to South Africa and
we visited Sato and the children in this
school sang to us and we danced and it
was very very moving
what but what was interesting was we had
a nap as a native South African tour
guide helping us and he surprised me
alarmed me when he said it was there
were better times during the apartheid
because now most of us are unemployed
and we've been fired from our jobs
because they have to give us fair wages
and I was thinking it's like in the
Hebrew Bible and Exodus when the Jews
escaped from bondage and slavery from
Egypt and then they started complaining
in the desert if we want to go back to
slavery that's when you were speaking
about freedom being so yeah difficult so
I would like your comments on because I
heard it more than once from other black
South Africans that there had better
times before I will say this I cannot
speak for everyone in South Africa and I
acknowledge that through a combination
of the hard work of my parents luck on
my part and hard work I I know that I'm
in a position of privilege and so I
cannot speak for everyone who may not
have the same things that I do but I but
I do know this freedom as I say is hard
work just because you achieve it does
not mean now everything is going to be
good and a lot of the time the fault
falls at the feet of those who delivered
the promises of liberation if we look at
the stories across the
and we even see that in America now the
promises that are made by the
politicians of those of a better life of
those of a life that will
instantaneously become beneficial for
all you know and and in South Africa
that's what the ANC promised at the time
they said free housing and free
everything and you know it was it was
this world that was promised that it was
like now that you've defeated you know
the oppressor everything will be open to
you you will you will get to enjoy the
spoils but the truth is what you have
achieved is the ability to work for the
spoils and it's a tough thing and those
liberators now have to work on providing
those opportunities think about it like
this in South Africa we had a country
that was designed for a minority that
didn't even make up 10% of the
population this is everything housing
plumbing the electrical grid system the
highways everything schools were just
design for for a tiny piece of the
population and so once the country is
now free obviously that means you're not
going to be able to get everybody to the
same level immediately and that means
that there's going to be a lot of
capital that needs to be injected that
means there's going to be a
redistribution of wealth that needs to
happen that needs to be there's going to
be a lot of systems that need to change
in order for that change to take effect
but when people say to me it's it was
better I struggle to grapple with the
idea that it is better to be enslaved
you know I
I I think one of the the closest
parallels and by no means am I saying
it's the same thing but it's when I read
stories of prisoners who tell the story
of how because of because of how hard we
make it in society to reintegrate some
prisoners would rather stay in prison
they go I get food I get a badge I know
what my life is I get to go to a library
and I'm part of a community and when you
set me free I see the world as a prison
and so the question we should be asking
ourselves is not was it better under
apartheid its that how do we create more
and more opportunities not just in South
Africa but even in America to free those
people or to give them access to that
freedom you know because in the book I
have the quote where I say you know they
say teach a man to fish and he will he
will fish he will eat for a day I mean
it's give a man a fish and he'll eat for
a day teach a man to fish and he will he
will live forever but one thing I always
think of as I go if you don't give him
the tool to fish all of that information
is useless you know so the rod is as
important as allowing him spirits
[Applause]
[Music]
yes since we do have limited time if you
can just really make them a question
that would be great
[Applause]
[Laughter]
hi Trevor my name is Melissa I was born
and raised in Puerto Rico and I and I
came here when I was already in my early
20s just about the time that you were
born I didn't know the difference
between black and white until I moved to
this country I did not face racism until
I moved here and I saw it in a different
way my grandmother was as dark as the
ground your shoes are on ya it have you
ever encountered racism and what have
you done in racism in this country and
what have you done about it at that
moment
yeah I've encountered racism in America
I guess it hasn't shaken me because you
know I come from a place where we have
some of the finest racism in the world
[Music]
you will struggle to shake me with what
you have here I find I find oftentimes
racism in my experience comes from a
place of fear strangely enough you know
a lot of the time I think we treat
racism as a cause and yet I see it as a
symptom
you know I people can disagree with me
but personally I see racism as the
symptom and the cause stems from many
different things but a lot of the time
that racism comes from a fear those that
have experienced racism from see me or
see the black man or see a brown man as
a threat to their livelihood as a threat
to their dominance as a threat to the
promise that they were given by their
fathers or to the leaders before who
told them that this was their land and
this was their future and to many people
the idea of sharing is the idea of
giving it all away and so oftentimes
when somebody's racist to me I'm lucky
in that none of the racial incidents
have been particularly physical and so
it's it's it's it's mostly words and you
know I'm a firm believer in most
emotions in the world or a choice that
we make you know things are happening to
us but the way we we respond to that is
an emotional choice and so if anything I
I smile and I send it right back I I
don't believe that you can spoil my day
because of something you say you know
you don't define me by saying that
[Applause]
[Music]
all right now I know most of you in line
are gonna hate me but we have time for
two more questions sorry and but you
know each of you have a book and in the
book all right let me finish let me
finish in the book is an email address
and I'm sure if you send an email to
that email address
it'll get to Trevor and I'm sure he'll
answer your promises politicians make
but they can't deliver on and then we
wonder why there's a revolution father
was white so why didn't you leave that
was a question I asked my mom funny
enough there were many South Africans
who did leave they went into exile they
left to other countries where they could
live a free life some left to go and
plan how they would come and and inspire
and spark a revolution others left
merely to escape what was happening I
asked my mom that when I discovered that
I didn't know we could leave I didn't
know that there was an option I only
knew the country I was in and one day I
asked my mom I said why the hell didn't
we leave once I knew because my dad is
Swiss and I was like once I saw what
Switzerland was I was like are you
kidding me
I was like we could have been skiing are
you kidding me and and my mom said one
of the most powerful things to me she
looked at me and she said she said leave
and go as she said this is my country
she said I'm not going to let somebody
chase me out of my country but I'm going
to stay here and claim what is mine
so that is it's as simple as that I
didn't leave because I didn't know we
could leave I don't think I would have
been as strong as my mother was but she
wasn't going to allow somebody to take
what was hers you know in exchange for
an easier life okay I made it
hi I'm Nina very nice to meet you I grew
up in America biracial clearly I'm
biracial and I experienced a lot of
colorism with racism within the actual
black community because I wasn't fully
black or in vice-versa on the white side
I wasn't fully white did you experience
that same color ISM in South Africa
growing up as a kid did the blacks ever
make you feel different from them and
look at you a certain way or treat you
differently because you weren't as dark
as they were and vice versa
no you know I was I was really lucky in
that I didn't experience that within the
African community and I think it is
partly because of the hierarchy that was
created and so I found that within the
black community I was welcomed because
you know in essence what I found
even when traveling the world a lot of
the time communities that are having a
tougher time or an experience that is
not particularly pleasant are more
welcoming to outsiders that choose that
experience because they go no one would
want to be here so who are we to judge
you come on in
and and so those communities are very
welcoming so I I'd never experienced
that from you know in African
communities I did however experience
that in colored communities and that was
a strange thing that I've learned and we
do that in life all the time
often times it is easier to be an
insider as an outsider than it is to be
an outsider
that's an insider and what I mean by
that is it was easier for me to be
accepted by black people because it was
a quick discussion and a decision that
was made immediately and that was
clearly we can see that we are different
you are choosing to be here you're
choosing to upset me and then we move on
from here whereas people who saw me as
being exactly like them questioned why I
wasn't because I culturally was not the
same and so I had people now rejecting
me because they felt that I was
rejecting them by being myself and that
is something we have to be careful of we
do that all the time in our communities
we have somebody who we feel should be
exactly like us and we shun them because
we feel they are living a life that is
different to ours when in fact they are
being true to themselves so that is
something I didn't experience at the
extreme levels but I know what your
you know I was I was standing in the
back and someone whispered in my ear
they said I always liked him because he
was smart and funny but now I also know
that he's a beautiful human being so I
want to thank you very very much
remarkable event thank you for being
here at the Maggie's I also want to take
Bob Bob Weisberg for the more remarkable
conversation as well thank you Bob
[Applause]
[Music]